[Aplausos]
não sou um fotógrafo convencional a
minha fotografia é captada pelo amor
o espírito de fotógrafo ea sensibilidade
a minha fotografia é cega
nasci no sertão do piauí nas cidades de
bom jesus e lá pelos 14 anos de idade
cursando o curso técnico em agropecuária
um professor de zootecnia e despertou a
fotografia
aos 21 anos venho para são paulo quando
trabalhava e perto da minha do meu
trabalho tinha uma instituição para sexo
e eu ajudava a esses jovens senhores e
senhoras a chegar até a instituição em
aos 28 anos devido ao vit bilateral
eu começo a perder a visão
e aí durante um ano
essa luta eu fiquei deficiente
sou baixa visão ou visão subnormal
e aí o que fazer
vou ficar em casa depressivo ou chorar
eu descobri que a melhor maneira de ser
de de lutar pela vida é quando a gente
conhece outras pessoas que tiveram o que
têm a deficiência como a gente nesse
processo de reabilitação eu conheci
pessoas que me falaram
somos deficientes mas temos que
trabalhar temos que ir lá ver
temos que viver temos que namorar temos
que ter uma vida normal
e aí vocês perguntam ea fotografia
eu achava que não poderia mais
fotografado devido a minha deficiência
visual e de repente eu descobri um
colega que está fazendo um curso
de fotografia na instituição em são
paulo e esse curso spray específico para
a pessoa com deficiência visual e aí de
repente o brilho dos meus olhos e
alegria volta novamente e aí eu falei eu
vou poder fotografar novamente comércio
do esporte e começa a fotografia como
que o fotógrafo senhores senhoras e
fotografo cola a minha sensibilidade a
minha fotografia é cega porque por mais
que haja toda a tecnologia hoje eu os
equipamentos fotográficos não existe
acessibilidade como celulares leitores
de tela
já a câmera não por isso que eu falo que
a fotografia cega porque os sentidos
para catar quando faz um retrato de uma
pessoa ou quando eu vou fotografar um
atleta de outra maneira eu sinto
primeiro eu tenho que fazer um exercício
de mentalizar essa imagem como atleta me
deu toda a base para mim poder
fotografar esporte
e aí vem a segunda oportunidade que o
ricardo rojas e convida para passar
desse time de fotógrafos que vão nos
jogos paraolímpicos rio 2016
aí o visual nessa equipe de 6 ó topo e
um cadeirante e lá pessoal a minha vida
muda de um jeito que vocês não têm noção
porque eu fui o primeiro deficiente
visual a fazer a cobertura dos jogos
para além do rio 2016 onde a minha
história hoje está sendo contado em mais
de 30 países com mais de 4.500 veículos
e quando eu estava lá fotografando eu
nem conseguia trabalhar direito porque
assim eu só queria uma entrevista
entrevista e e fotos as pessoas me
paravam na nas arenas e duas as emoções
mais fortes que eu tive foi um tradutor
japonesa ele chegou para mim e falou
joão já tive na tv eu tive na reportagem
essa história me emocionou bastante e dá
um abraço e eu abracei ele fiquei parado
nessa loucura hoje é do mundo de self a
pessoa só me pediu um abraço e é isso
que eu quero deixar para vocês
o preconceito contra qualquer que seja a
deficiência ela só existe quando é falta
conhecimento quando as pessoas não têm o
conhecimento sobre x deficiência então
eu acho que quando eu vou pra qualquer
palestra eu acho que a gente tem essa
obrigação como pessoa com deficiência em
ensinar às pessoas como que se trata as
pessoas com deficiência
você tá uma coisa que acontece muito com
a gente eu estou no ponto de ônibus e de
repente a pessoa
eu vou pedir ajuda para a pessoa leva
para onde eu falei senhora a senhora
pode me dar ajuda para melhor
não meu filho não tem dinheiro só tem
dois reais a rede que eu falei não eu
não quero dinheiro eu só quero que
separa o ônibus essa questão cultural no
brasil é de que as pessoas deficientes
elas se precisa dar uma esmola não dê
esmola para um deficiente de trabalho de
dignidade
a gente quer que seu consumidor a gente
quer ir ao teatro a gente quer
pela serpente cultura somos todos iguais
a gente a gente só quer é isso ser igual
o coração bate da mesma forma o sangue
que pulsa nas minhas veias também
impulsiona as suas veias
a gente não quer ser diferente todo
mundo tem sua limitação a minha é visual
mas eu sempre fui apaixonado pela
fotografia e isso não me impediu de ser
um bom fotógrafo
por isso não deixe de acreditar nos
sonhos
o meu sonho agora é tóquio japão 2020
obrigado